hi i'm rich i'd like to publish a data
table on quora.pub that i could share
with the world
great so let's make a new quarter
document
and what we get is a core document which
is filled out with some boilerplate
i'm going to switch my editor from
visual to source mode and edit the file
directly
i'd like to share a table poll from the
gt packets examples
i'm going to use that in this code chunk
i'm going to save this now
just to check that it looks good i'm
going to render this i have quarto
installed i went to quarter.org and got
the
uh installation file for that
great and now this renders as a core uh
document
and it looks really good scrolling up
and down and i'm quite satisfied with
this table
now the next step i'm going to publish
this inside of quarter pub so we don't
do that in the console we go to terminal
and because we have the chordo uh cli
installed i'm just going to type in
quarto and publish
and now what it does is it shows you a
list of providers but what we want is
quarter pub so i'm going to hit enter on
that
it's going to ask you to authorize
i'm going to hit capital y
and now we're brought to the quoto
assignment page i have an account if you
don't uh sign up right here at the
bottom
uh but mike i have a sign in through
github so i'm going to click on that and
as you can see here it just takes me
right in
and it asks me to authorize i will allow
this
and now i can close this window and now
it's asking me for the name of the
document i'm satisfied with that i'm
going to hit enter
and right now it's going to publish that
through the usual way and it's going to
show you some additional information
about what's doing when it's publishing
this doesn't take very long
and it just creates the site publishes
it
and you are now in the immense view of
my published table on quarter.hub
it's showing you your table
uh and it's giving you some controls
it's telling you where it's published at
this is actually the link you need to uh
for the entry for the table contest i'm
going to click on this and this is what
other people will see they'll see this
exact page and you'll just need to copy
this
and use that
when you make your entry
and it's as simple as that we've created
and published a table to quarter.hub
can't wait to see what you create